it is pronounced Moreau see John Moreau
see he's the pace ball insider mlb.com
columnist good morning John how are you
let's do the whole interview in Italian
John help me in any language Bryce
Harper is gonna be paid a lot of money
here but are the Dodgers now the
front-runner
that's a great question Dan and I
believe if the answer is not yes
yet it is inching in that direction I'm
a believer that if Harper truly wanted
to sign with the Phillies he would have
done so by now and that's been said I
think it's very very true the Dodgers
one of the big things that's happened in
baseball this week Dan is the fact that
no one are not oh who was high on the
Dodgers list for next offseason has
signed a mega dollar extension to stay
in Colorado so now that the Dodgers
cannot chase our nod or next winter
perhaps there's a bit more money in the
budget for this winter which is now of
course become this spring and Harper
becoming more and more plausible I think
for them and I was told Dan yesterday
that if the Dodgers just get close now
we think the Phillies I don't have this
confirmed but I think they're probably
somewhere in that range of 10 years and
300 million dollars plus if the Dodgers
get close and again close what's 50
million or so among friends here but if
they get close I think the chances are
pretty good that Harper would sign with
the Dodgers even if they are not the
biggest offer but can you do something
that seems a little more financially
plausible or smart or there's some
fiscal sanity involved in this like a
five or six year deal where Harper gets
more money per season therefore Scott
Boras his agent can hold his head high
and say see what I do for my my clients
exactly and I think that there's been
this back-and-forth about how how
willing Harper is to take less money in
fewer years to sign on the west coast
which we believe is his preference I
think if you go thirty-five million
dollars a year and again
I'm spending somebody else's money here
but if I look at it this way thirty five
million dollars a year times five years
times six years then at least Scott
Boras can come back and say I got my
client the biggest per year deal in
baseball history right now the per year
record is about thirty four million
dollars signed by Zack Greinke with the
Diamondbacks and if you get to 35 then
you set a new standard maybe you get an
opt-out early in the deal so that way
Scott can say hey I've got my guy he's
got the best four year deal ever in
baseball history he also has the early
opt-out to test the market again if he
wants to and he goes to the team that I
believe right now Dan that he wants to
go to even worse from Las Vegas so LA is
something of a hometown team close and
as close as you could probably get being
from Las Vegas he would have spring
training in Arizona again close to his
home in Vegas and a bit to the earlier
discussion this hour Dan he is a Lakers
fan now I'm not going to say that your
favorite basketball team is going to
guide where you're going to sign play
baseball for the next five ten years of
your life but he is used to the LA
sports scene he is that has been his
team since childhood and while I don't
think that's the number one factor by
any stretch of the imagination
it's probably someone on the list from a
standpoint of being very very
comfortable with the LA sports culture
well why doesn't Magic Johnson in his
role with the Dodgers just say to LeBron
hey would you place a call to Bryce
Harper it's a great question I I would
expect that they've already thought of
that I don't have a confirm that it's
happened but wouldn't that be a nice bit
of recruiting in LeBron very buddy's
used to what it's like to be a national
accorded free agent I would actually
think if the Lakers won the Lakers the
Dodgers want to bring in a LeBron as the
closer here I think that's actually
brought one of the best ideas I've heard
in this somewhat metering and really
unprecedented off season schedule here
for MLB if you could have Aaron judge
for the next six years in Bryce Harper
for the next six years
same price go with it's a great question
that they're basically the same age
which tells you a lot about the
different scale you've got with was
coming out of a high school player and
actually even earlier than that for
Bryce because he went to that 17 year
old
laughter for him a very unique schedule
for him I would say I would go with
judge I just think that the the powers
have been more consistent right now but
there's a lot to be said for Harper to
Harper both Harper and Judge tremendous
from a marketability standpoint that's a
great question I would give the slight
edge to judge but it is very very close
what if I threw mookie betts in there
I'm a huge Mookie Betts fan I voted for
him for the MVP this past year I think
all best all-around players in the game
I think Mookie for what he does on the
bases and defensively I would put Mookie
Betts ahead of both Harper and Judge in
terms of on the field and Mookie is a
phenomenal story off the field as well
it just does all the right things in the
community I think Mookie Betts I would
say right now I would take Mookie Betts
over either judge or Harper
Mookie or Mike Trout I I still think
that overall the best player in the game
is trout and so I think right now I'd
have to give the edge to Trout his
numbers are so historically great over
time that I think he gets the nod I
think we all want to see trout have
success and play in the playoffs he has
played three playoff games in his entire
career and he is still looking for his
first playoff win and when you look at
what made Derek Jeter an icon in the
previous generation among many things it
was that he played for the Yankees and
that he was on our television sets every
October winning and trout has not done
that yet Mookie Betts has done this now
he is one the MVP and he's won the World
Series so I think that I would still say
trout deserves that status as the best
all-around player in the game but Mookie
is right there and I voted for Mookie as
my MVP last year because I believe he
made the biggest impact for that team
for the Boston Red Sox and I think what
Mookie does on the field off the field
think about what he did during the World
Series last year bringing food to the
homeless during the course of the World
Series after a game after a World Series
game he just has such great presence of
mind for what he means to the sport to
our country I think Mookie Betts is a
phenomenal person for our entire sports
landscape here in the States right now I
still can't help and one of my guys one
of the Danites McLovin is a Phillies fan
and I kept saying to him you know
I'm not hearing that Bryce Harper likes
Philadelphia he loves Philadelphia's
offer he just doesn't want to play in
Philadelphia is is that you know cuz
Scott Boras is trying to drum up any
interest he can is that what happened
here that the Phillies gave them an
offer that they're having a hard time
refusing well it's a great point and I I
do think and I'm and Bryce Harper's not
told me this directly but if you look at
the landscape and the way the offseason
has played out I agree with that line of
thinking and he and I'm I want to be
careful here and make this point I think
part of the reason has nothing to do
with the Phillies themselves or even the
city but let's think about this this is
let's take a step back if he signs with
the Phillies and he plays in the
National League East for a different
team every time he goes to DC he'll
probably be booed he'll be booed in
Atlanta which is always booed him he'll
be booed in New York which is always
booed him and if he struggles in Philly
he'll be boos that's a lot of booze for
your life Dan for the entire season for
the next ten years you want to sign up
to be booed at minimum you're going to
get booed on the road no matter what and
you might get booed at home if things
don't go the right way whereas if you go
and play in LA or even San Francisco
which is courted him it's a different
Coast different division closer to home
Spring trading closer to home and if you
go back to DC I believe he'll be
received fundamentally differently Dan
if he goes to DC wearing a Giants
uniform or a Dodgers uniform as compared
to their nearest in Division geographic
rival right to the north that that would
be a it be difficult for him I think to
still be viewed in the same favorable
light by DC sports fans if he's got the
Phillies jersey on that if he's wearing
the Dodgers uniform or the Giants yeah
you're making almost 40 million a year
boo who is what I would say but
something John enjoys spring training
great to read your stuff and thanks for
joining us again my pleasure gentlemen
thanks for indulging my brief Italian I
didn't trust my Italian enough to care
the rest of the segment but thanks for
indulging that a little bit alright John
Morrissey for more dance
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]